- Dwelling on what you (beep) up on
is the quickest way for
the next thing not to work.
All great stuff, especially
when you're innovating
doesn't happen right away.
Number one mistake so many people make
is they care about what other people have.
I don't give a (beep) what anybody has.
If I have more, if I have less.
It doesn't matter, I worry about myself.
- He's an American entrepreneur, investor
and four times New York
Times best selling author.
He's best known as a digital marketer
and social media pioneer.
He's an angel investor or advisor to Uber
Birchbox, Twitter, Facebook
Snapchat, and Tumblr.
He's Gary Vaynerchuk
and here's my take on his top 10 rules
for success volume two.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it as well
so other people can be inspired.
Also when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself as well, enjoy.
(upbeat inspiring music)
- What if I told you this
was the last Monday morning
of your life?
What if I told you you'd die this week?
Would you complain about your crap job
or that test you don't want to take?
I doubt it.
You'd go much higher level thinking.
Well that's really what it takes.
It takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now.
If you're begrudging
what you're about to do.
If you're not looking forward to it.
Look, I respect practicality.
You got to go through school
because your parents want to.
You got to pay your rent.
You got student loans.
I get it.
But please recognize the
world we're living in.
We're living in a world where
there is so much more opportunity.
This internet thing created
way more opportunity
for all of us, way more.
And look, you might not even be alive.
Like, your mom and dad could have had sex
like, three minutes later
and you wouldn't even exist.
And you're complaining.
You could have ended
up being a bus, a tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head down sad
on a Monday morning.
I'm going to make Monday
morning my (beep).
I'm going to make you
Saturday, Monday morning.
That's what I want to do every morning
and that's what I want from you.
Please, take a step back
and think about how
awesome it actually is.
And then, recognize that
you can attack the world
in a totally different way
because you are lucky enough to be born
during this era.
So many people come up to me and say
"Gary, it's so hard."
I look at their Instagram
and they're not posting any
of their content with hashtags
which is a by accident
way to pick up exposure
in a world where they have no money.
When you have no money.
When I took over my dad's business
it did $3 million a
year, 10% gross profit.
$300,000 before expenses.
My first year marketing
budget was $14,000.
When you have no money.
And I built that business from a three
to a $60 million business in five years.
I had to make every penny perfect.
So I was right about
email marketing in '96
and I was right, because of
that I had 91% open rates.
When Google Adwords came
out, the day it came out
I paid five cents a click for words
before anybody bid me up
and I was super right and that worked.
- How much is that luck versus preparation
and do you ever get anything wrong?
What do you do when you make a mistake?
- I get everything wrong.
It's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong I'm
moving onto the next thing.
Like, dwelling on what you (beep) up on
is the quickest way for
the next thing not to work.
Right?
- Yup.
(applause and cheering)
- So I think I do everything.
I mean, you know this.
This is a fun thing to say.
Some people in the back know this.
I was a break-out Youtube
star in the first year.
2006, I decided that the right strategy
was to leave Youtube completely
and go to Viddler
because Viddler offered
me equity in their company
and I've left an enormous
amount of attention.
I deviated from my intention thesis
to do short-term economics
in equity in a company.
And I lost.
I lost.
When D-Rock finally came
into my life two years ago
and we started to try
to build up my Youtube
for the first time
I was sitting on 40,000 followers
in a world where I could have had millions
if I had just stayed the course.
So I make mistakes all the time.
I'm re-working VaynerMedia everyday
because it's based on a
mistake I made the prior year.
I just don't give a
(beep) about my mistakes.
Everybody else cares about your mistakes.
If you're worried about your own mistakes
you've already lost.
- Sometimes a lot of people
may try a new initiative
and then they don't get
an immediate reaction
and they think it's a failure.
- [Gary] That's right.
- I watch your Youtube videos
with the Wine Library.
You know, you had so
much content out there.
How did you stick in there?
How did you keep yourself motivated?
- Because I believe in my strategies
and I'm patient as (beep).
Like, all great stuff
especially when you're innovating
doesn't happen right away.
This notion of like, "Oh Gary, I tried it.
"I spent 500 bucks on Facebook
ads, it doesn't work."
Well what if your video sucked?
What if your product and service sucks?
I tend to do things that are very early.
That has been my career.
When I do things, I believe in them.
I stick with them based on intuition.
Even though for 18 months
nobody watched my wine videos at all
I knew it was right, I was right.
There's been things I've done
that I jumped off of very quickly.
I started a Gary Vee app, VeeCHAT.
Like V-E-E, like WeChat.
That was funny for my fans.
Great CRM one-on-one.
Didn't feel right after a week or two.
Spent plenty of money building it.
Knew, stopped it after a couple months.
Wine Library TV, five
years, every day Youtube
decided to change it to Daily Grape.
InSolar App, you can buy stuff.
Subscription for reviews.
It was a lot of fun.
Only did it for five months, stopped it
because it didn't feel right anymore.
It's always hard to know when
to jump off something new.
But I find that people
don't believe in what they're doing.
They hear a guru
and they do it begrudgingly
because their boss wants them to
or they're like, "Well Gary's right a lot
"So let me do it."
But they don't believe it.
And so then they jump,
they're looking for no's
instead of yes's.
Everything I do, every
business development
every event I do, every time I try
a new marketing tactic or sales tactic
I'm looking for the yes.
- Right.
- I'm looking for the yes
and if the no punches me
well then I'm like,
"Crap, the no punched me."
I believe the majority of people
when they try new tactics
are looking for the no
and you're going to be getting a lot
of subtle no's immediately.
- [Host] Right.
- And so I think that's why that happens.
You need to care about everything
and it starts with yourself.
Look yourself in the mirror
and ask yourself, "What
do I want to do every day
"For the rest of my life?"
Do that.
I promise you can monetize that (beep).
If you love Alf, do an Alf blog.
If you collect Smurfs, Smurf it up.
Whatever you need to do, do it.
(audience laughing)
So many people are talking about
"I can't monetize, I can't monetize."
There's a billion 70 year old douchebags
that are in control right now.
But, the number two person
that 34 year old lady
she's going to buy your (beep).
She's going to put the
advertising on your stuff.
It's coming.
Stop crying and just keep hustling.
I am desperate for people to start
defining their hopes and dreams
and wants and needs on their terms.
Not on what I say.
I don't care if you want
to hustle 18 hours a day.
I really don't.
I really, really don't.
I don't care if you want
to buy the New York Jets.
I don't care what you want or need.
You need to care about
what you want and need.
You can't worry about what I'm saying.
You can't worry about whoever your
flavor of the month is right?
Maybe I'm your flavor
of the month right now.
Maybe your consistent flavor of the life
is your mom's point of view.
Is your older brother who's
guided you with wisdom
but wants you to be a lawyer
but you don't want to be a lawyer.
You want to be a street artist.
You want to take the chance
of being an entrepreneur.
Or the reverse, or the reverse.
No one preaches and loves entrepreneurship
more than me
but I think you see me all the time
talking about self awareness, are you one?
This is the golden era
for entrepreneurship.
People ask me for selfies.
This will go away.
It may not go away for me
but it's going to go away
and you know, entrepreneurship
like a rap artist, like a baseball player.
Like a heavyweight, nobody
cares who the heavyweight
champion of the world is right now.
Nobody cares who's an active astronaut.
But they surely did in 1969 and 1954
for heavyweight champ
or you know, they change, they change.
And it will always change
and it will continuously change
and right now, entrepreneurship
is in this pedestal.
It's having its moment.
And what I'm fearful of
is that you watch my videos,
you see my Instagram quotes.
And what I want to clarify for everybody
is I hope you understand.
I am not giving advice to everybody.
The only advice I'd like
to give to everybody
is to do you.
To find what your north star is.
To understand yourself.
To understand what your
work/life balance ambitions are.
How much, what your
financial ambitions are.
What your life challenges are.
The problems that you want
to try to solve and cure
as we all do as humans.
Trying to climb those different
mountains in our lives.
What makes you tick?
That is all that matters.
Don't do, you know I don't do DailyVee
or all these videos for you to be like me.
I don't think anybody should be like me.
Boy, there are enormous
amounts of pressures
and sacrifices that I recognize
are just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else
but it's also not
healthy or valuable to me
to do some of the things
that you want me to do.
Like, it's not fun for me to work 9-5.
I will break, I will be
as equally devastated
as you would be to work
till midnight every day.
And so we just need a call to action
for everybody to recognize
we have to stop judging everybody else.
I'm not judging you.
I'm creating content for
you to use as a barometer
to try to figure out what you like
and what you don't like
and I'm trying to provide value
through my words, my actions
and my content to bring to people
to amplify their worlds.
And that's really it.
That's the clarification.
Like, I don't want people to be like me.
I don't want people to do me.
I want people to do themselves.
And they just have to start
with understanding themselves
and not trying to be
like me in this moment
or that person the next moment.
Or that person the next moment.
The people that most win
are in tune with themselves
and figure themselves out.
The problem is, if you
have the greatest hammer
and the greatest screwdriver
and the greatest wrench, the greatest
in front of you.
If you don't use them properly
you will lose.
- [Host] Right.
- If there's a nail that I
have to put in that ground
but I take the wrench and I hit it
when the hammer was right there.
It still comes down to the practitioner
and you have to be good at your craft.
And you have to love your,
if you don't love sales
if you don't love it, you have no chance.
Because it's so hard, it's so painful.
There's so much rejection.
- [Host] Right.
- So those are the things I think about.
- So, technology has enabled
as you just said there
that the person is equally important.
- [Gary] More important.
- Right, and going back to--
- More important.
Like I apologize for jumping in
but let me make it perfectly straight.
If I go play Roger Federer
right now in tennis
and I have the greatest
tennis racket ever made.
Like taken for the Mar's new resources
and he took a John
McEnroe 1974 tennis racket
he would whip my ass.
(laughs)
Like, I am crushing sales people
that have every sales force,
every one of your competitors
37 features, upgraded, went
to every PRO conference
watching this.
I will beat their ass in
sales every day of the week.
Pure talent.
- [Audience Member]
Because you regularly say
that failure propels you.
Are there any instances in your past truly
where you couldn't get over it and why?
- Nope.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] And that's why--
- By the way, by the way!
That's the same answer for
everybody in this room.
That's what humans are good at.
We all fail, we've all failed.
Like, there are.
My parents haven't been killed, my child.
I mean, there's people that
have their children die.
Like could you imagine?
Like the (beep) I deal with.
Listen, unfortunately or fortunately
depends on how one wants to look at it
I'm a pretty optimistic guy.
I lost three of my four grandparents
before I was really, before I knew them.
Two before I was born
and one very early on.
So, you know it's easy for me to be happy.
I have my (beep) in the right order.
The health and well being of my family.
And there's nothing even
remotely close to that.
Not even remotely.
People have gotten through much worse.
This is why I'm trying to
recall our grandparents
and our great-grandparents.
People were persecuted and killed
and like I just, we do
not have real headaches.
You know, I don't know why I have this
highly emotional and then
completely un-emotional
part of me
but I mix them together
to create the balance
and that's what works for me.
So of course there's nothing
that I couldn't get up from.
Like every other human
ever besides somebody
who now lives in some weird cave
that we don't know about.
(audience laughs)
You know what I mean?
- [Woman] I do.
- We are strong as (beep).
We're really (beep) strong.
We're just being sold that we're not.
Because there's a lot of money.
A lot of money in telling us
that we're not pretty enough
thin enough, smart enough, good enough.
(beep) that.
I want to tell you you're the (beep) best.
Go do (beep).
- [Woman] I've been feeling a little bit
unmotivated and I've been feeling
like I should be doing something
or I should be, just like I feel like
I should be pulled in different.
I'm feeling, uninspired basically.
That's my question.
How do you get, when you lose inspiration
or you lose motivation,
how do you get it back?
- I get it back by remembering
that you might die tomorrow.
- [Woman] That's true.
- So, I'm inspired by practicality
and reality and the truth
which is it is ridiculously impossible
to become a human being.
I am one.
I have other good things
going for me as a human being.
And I'm just grateful.
You're dwelling and looking
at what you don't have
versus looking at what you have.
If you actually looked at what you had
your health, you know living in America.
You know, who the heck knows
what you be on your list
if you actually spent all
your time looking at that
versus, "I don't have a million dollars.
"I'm not famous.
"I don't have this."
If you spent all your
time on what you have
versus what you don't have
you would be the happiest girl on Earth.
- [Man] Should I do this on the side
or take a gap year and try to launch it?
- Both work.
- [Man] Both? Okay.
- [Man] Which one is best?
- I don't know you well enough, you know.
You know what I mean?
They both work.
- [Man] Yes.
- Which one do you want to do?
- [Man] I would like to
try to take a gap year.
- So take a gap year.
- [Man] But I'm scared.
- Well that's why you're asking.
- [Man] Yeah, which one will you do?
- I wouldn't take either.
- [Man] What will you do then?
- I can't answer that for you.
Fear is holding you back.
You know what you want to do.
The only reason you're not doing it
is because you're scared of doing
what you actually want to do.
Right?
Are you scared to do it because
your parents won't like it?
- [Man] No, my parents
actually support me.
- Okay, so what are
you scared of? Failing?
- [Man] Not failing but um,
still being in the same place
when my friends are at the next level.
- Huge mistake.
You don't want the same
thing your friends want.
- [Man] No.
- So why the (beep) do
you care what they have?
Number one mistake so many people make
is they care about what other people have.
I don't give a (beep) what anybody has.
If I have more, if I have less.
It doesn't matter, I worry about myself.
The fact that you're worrying about
other people's accomplishments
is already a losing formula.
You need to get rid of that first
then you can focus on yourself.
- [Man] Thank you.
- You understand?
You know to be great, I
think you have to fight.
And I very much thing that my success
is a product of some level of skill.
But I do think I win
because I outwork people.
I really do believe that.
I do believe that 100%.
And I'm not sure that if my
dad didn't set that example
that I'd even have the ability to think
one could work that hard.
The fact that I've been
working 19 hours a day
every day for the last
20 years is easy for me.
It's the only gear I do right?
I was poor, I sucked (beep) at school.
It was the only gear I had.
You know I think you need to recognize
that your biggest advantage
is that you're hungrier
than your competitor
and that if you're not
applying your one advantage
which is your work ethic
and the hours that you have
to put into your business
well then you're going to come up short.
I sit here with enormous assumptions
around all of you
that you're just too soft to beat me.
Right, but I think that
you've had it better.
And that that alone doesn't
allow you to beat me.
Somebody will come with the
counter culture point of view
and be like, "Gary that's cool
"But I don't have to work that hard
"Because I'm working smarter."
Yeah me too (beep).
I work hard and smart, now what?
Look, there's a 12 hour, 10 hour
eight hour, 15 hour work day.
You can finish a lot of things
in those 18, 12, nine hours.
Or you can finish medium amounts of things
or lightweight things.
People focus on too many small details.
Way too many people in this room
are going to spend the next
30, 40 years of their lives
trying to check the boxes
on the things that they're not as good at
and that, you're going to waste
a (beep) load of time and lose.
I highly recommend, for all you hustlers
because there's a lot of you.
There's a lot of you
that are always talking
about, "Gary I do work hard."
And you do, you work for 16 hours.
Some people just don't
have the attention span
or the capacity to remember
or like, there's a lot
of things I can't learn.
I was a very poor student
because the subject matter bored me.
And if I was forced to become great
at understanding the great
artists of the 20th century
I'm in big trouble.
And so I would tell people
to bet on their strengths.
You need to bet on your strengths
and don't give a (beep)
about what you suck at.
And to put themselves in a position
to win with their strengths
because that is absolutely the
straightest line to success.
Greatness comes from adversity
and looking the challenge in the eye
and having the intestinal fortitude
to kind of, to step up and go after it.
(soft piano music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
How do you like our volume two series?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from Gary today?
What did he say that had
the biggest impact on you?
What lesson is your favorite
and you're going to apply
immediately to your life
or business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout-out
to Richard Galvez.
Richard, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
And I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- [COLSAUCE] Amy asks, "A
professor once said to me
"It's better to be a big
fish in a small pond.
"Do you agree?"
- Amy, this. You know I'm
going to be very upfront
on this question.
This is a good way to bang out the show.
That sounds like a loser professor to me.
It's small time thinking.
I don't subscribe to it.
There's a lot of practicality in it right?
It's a lot easier to be the most
successful business man
in St. Louis, Missouri
than it is to be in the world right?
So I understand the thesis
but honestly, that to
me is very conservative
not in my DNA thinking.
That could be great
advice for a lot of people
who are delirious and think
they're better than they are.
Though I love to drive through
self esteem and optimism
and I think early in your life
you should absolutely
shoot for the highest stars
that you can.
I think as life moves on
and time moves on
you need to become more practical.
You've got bills and kids
and all those kind of things.
But to start off one's
career in the first 20 years
call it till you're 40
to be in that thinking.
I think that limits.
There have been so many people
who have hedged and that
settled in their lives
and honestly, I'm not
the kind of character
that's going to play
in that kind of sphere.
I'm going in a different direction.
It's what comes natural to me.
But it's also because I
think I can be the biggest
and the baddest in any game I play.
It's just how I'm wired.
I think this comes down to
it's probably very good advice to some
and it's probably
atrocious advice to others.
And this is why I continue to say
if I can inject anything into anybody
it would be self awareness
because it would help
you answer this question.
Because for a lot of people, it's probably
really solid advice.
For me, and for many of you watching this
it's crap advice.
- [AshleyFidget] Allen
asks, "As we've seen
"You hate wasting time.
"But how do you adjust on days
"Nothing is going right?"
- Well there's no such thing.
Luckily, I mean there's.
(knocks on table)
I don't remember a day
when nothing went right.
I mean, first and foremost.
The way I really deal with it
if we want to get zen about this
and a lot of you know this.
Is, as long as everybody's healthy
everything went right.
I always quantify.
When business doesn't go well
I default quickly to
"Oh business is bull (beep)
it's all about life."
You know, like how cute my kids are.
Thank God my parents are alive.
I quickly switch from, I don't dwell.
You know, I'm not good at dwelling.
I love speed and I
don't like wasting time.
Dwelling, complaining
wishing, hoping.
You know, pondering how you wish it was
is the single biggest
waste of time in life
and in business.
Like, the bottom line is
we all wish things.
I wish I was 6'4, the single
best looking guy in the world
and the quarterback of the New York Jets
that has won 19 straight Super Bowls.
I wish that.
I mean I wish that.
I mean, I just wish that.
I wish that.
And in the same way that that's funny
is the same way to wish that
like, that deal went through
or that employee took the job
or that person didn't quit
or that concept didn't work out.
I mean, I've had multiple divisions
multiple strategies here
at Wine, at Wine Library.
At VaynerMedia that haven't worked
in the last 12 months.
Yet, we're dismantling it.
And so much like anything else
it's like the next, it's the next play.
Using artistic stuff, like if
you're doing a Broadway play.
What are you going to mess
up a line and just stop?
And just cry on stage?
You just got to go to the next line.
I mean, you just got
to keep moving forward
and so how do I handle it?
Easily, I'm a (beep) champ on this issue.
I'm a champion.
I am an absolute champion on this issue.
Meaning like, I'm prepared
for the punches in the face.
I expect things not to go well.
It's kind of the way I
prep for a Jets game.
Saturday night, nobody
likes being around me
because I'm just devastated, it's all bad.
We're going to lose, this
is what's going to happen.
We're going to lose.
You know, like I'm
subconsciously like that.
But unlike the Jets where
I say that outwardly
these guys can tell you
I'm only on winning on
offense at all times.
- [JoeWhitmarsh] Adam asks
"I feel like I've lost my hustle.
"Help, what do I do?"
- Adam, anybody who's losing their hustle
has a lot of variables.
And there's a lot of
variables in this episode.
This is the variable episode
where there's a lot of contact sports.
There's not just direct answers today.
Listen, you might not be passionate
about your north star anymore.
I've been going through something.
Let me actually bring
some shattering news here.
For the first time in my life
I've been thinking about weird things
like sabbaticals and
building a business school
in Haiti for five years
and like, I love.
Listen, I'm still all about
buying the New York Jets
and it's the process of that and the game
but it's amazing for me
to be in tune with myself.
The maturity as you get older.
Just like my kids are six and three
and they're interesting.
Like they're interesting.
And like, I start projecting.
What do they look like at 13 and 15?
It would be really cool to like
I don't believe in the school system
as much as everybody.
Do I just take them and
go do something rogue?
Just different things, you just evolve.
And you might have just
lost your north star.
The thing that you
thought you were going for
might not be.
It's why I was always happy
that I didn't want a million bucks
or I didn't want fame
or I didn't want a car or private plane.
All these little things.
It was fun to be like,
"I want to buy the Jets."
And what that always meant to me
was I want the process of buying the Jets.
Which means I get to hustle forever
because that's my, that's who I am.
Maybe you've lost who you are
or what you want
or maybe you've accomplished kind of.
Or maybe you feel it's achievable.
I would be crushed if I thought
what I wanted to achieve
was super achievable.
I mean, it happened to
me in the wine business.
It's happening at Vayner.
Like, as Vayner is becoming a player
in the agency world
and we're not like ugh.
Now, we're like oh.
Like, and soon we're going to be like ah.
Like you know?
That's not as fun for me.
I like being the underdog.
I like the climb you know?
I like that.
So, maybe that's happened.
Maybe you're just tired.
I mean, I think one of the
things that the New York Jets do
for me that nobody understands
is those hours.
Actually, you just caught
something on DailyVee right?
Me talking to Jeff.
That was the first time I talked business
during a Jet's game in 15 years.
I looked at my phone at the wrong time.
It was a very big thing.
And I only spent a second on it.
Like, I am escaped and relaxed.
And by the way, I didn't care about it.
Like that's how excited.
Those three, four hours of escapism.
Maybe you need some vacation time.
Maybe you need to look
at the people around you.
Maybe you need a change.
Maybe you need to break up with your
boyfriend or girlfriend.
There's a lot of intense, different things
that could be happening.
Or maybe you could take a step back
and really listen to this statement.
Which is, you've lost your hustle
because you've really are not in tune
to why you were doing it.
Right? You're just not in
tune to what you're doing.
That you're maturing and realizing
like, a Ferrari.
Or a phat watch.
Or court side tickets.
Or custom Nikes.
I just wanted to show them.
You know, is not what you're living for.
And so...
You know it's funny tonight I'm going to
the Charity Water Gala.
I never thought of myself 10 years ago
as somebody who would be
so involved in non-profits.
Sitting on the board of
Pencils to Promise, donating.
I was you know, I was old school.
I'm 40, I'm older.
Like, this new narrative
of much better people
and that's what I think you guys all are.
I think you're a much better generation.
I grew up thinking I'll get rich
and when I'm old I'll be
like, giving out money
and doing that stuff.
So you just evolve right?
And so maybe you, like me
like I've haven't gone completely
like I don't have enough money.
My kids can give away all the money
but I can't, I don't have that luxury yet.
But maybe you want to do non-profit.
Maybe you want to build schools
for Pencils of Promise
and we'll take you to Laos.
Maybe you've lost your purpose.
So take a good step back, shut down.
Shut down for 24, 48, 72 hours.
Go away.
Go away like this.
This is how I want you to shut down.
Go to Airbnb.
This is the 2016 way to shut down.
Go to Airbnb, find a very remote place.
You know, time, do I have to go?
Oh I'm keeping something,
yeah I'm just wrapping up
the show, sorry.
Go to Airbnb, find a very remote place
that you can get to at a low cost.
Like a crappy cabin far
away on a four hour drive
where you can just drive because you can
or like, somebody will drive you there
or hitchhike, I don't give a crap.
Lowest cost, furthest away, seclusion.
And just be with yourself
and start talking to yourself for real.
For like, really talk
to yourself for real.
One of the great things I do with myself
is I talk to myself for real.
And really, nobody is a harsher critic
and a bigger fan of themselves than me.
And I think that friction
in both directions matters.